whoever you are wherever you go someone
wants to murder you
are you afraid
hey youtubers is Charlie so big surprise
for Monday is that there's a new Game of
Thrones trailer you have to remember
that even though this trailer presents a
juxtaposition of certain characters like
bran in the night's king it doesn't
always necessarily mean the season's
gonna go down that way
HBO marketing cuts these trailers not
the people that actually make the show
so tell you with a grain of salt but I
do like the way they present different
characters here like you have the Tower
of joy where a Ned Stark Howlin Reed in
a couple of his friends a couple other
Knights went to rescue his sister Lyanna
Stark it was actually William Dustin
Ethan Glover Martin Cassell theable and
Mark Rhys well they had to fight out
three members of the Targaryen Kings
garb which is why their armor has
Targaryen sigils on it Arthur Dayne was
one of those people he wasn't a dual
wielder so I don't know if they've
changed that for the TV show I guess if
they're not gonna do the sword dawn then
dual wielding would be a nice concession
but these just might be the other two
Kingsguard so Arthur Dayne might be
somewhere up closer to the actual tower
but you can actually see it in this shot
here just the way they reversed it from
previous trailers and like everyone's
theories about the episode one titled
the red woman as in they fight their way
up to the tower and finally on a Stark
lying in a pool of blood making her a
red woman they're definitely going to be
a couple of red women in episode 1
continuing the theme of the trailer we
see the murdered Jon Snow whose corpse
is now slowly turning blue
Sansa still on the run from Ramsay's men
the night's king with his army looking
like they're going to murder someone I
know there's the scene where brain finds
him in the vision he's like oh [ __ ] but
that doesn't mean that that's happening
near this scene right here this seems
like something totally different I guess
going with the murder theme if you
wanted to talk about Samwell being
murdered you could say that the drowned
God is slowly trying to murder him with
his giant storm the faith militant
slowly closing in on Jaime while he
stands over Marcela's body Jamie looking
murderously at the high Sparrow
Ramsay's army trying to murder the
combined armies of Sansa Stark don't
know that I would go so far as to say
the Dothraki are trying to murder
Daenerys it really depends on where that
first episode picks up but I think
they're definitely going to have a
battle of wills between her and Khal
jhaqo she's gonna have to find a way to
win them over
marriage is one solution to that we
finally see ilaria sand and some door
and so confirmed Dorne happening during
season 6 she still wants to revenge
murder the Lannisters now Jaime and
Cersei probably
want to murder them to the harpy's
looking like they're gonna try and
murder Tyrion this season I'm sure he's
gonna enjoy that and I really curious to
see where Melisandre fits into this
equation because she's kind of like a
third party bystander like it's pretty
easy to assume that the Brothers of the
Nights Watch that mutiny against Jon
Snow probably don't trust her so maybe
they'll try and murder her too are you
gonna have a lot of fun giving the gift
of the many-faced God which basically
means murdering a bunch of people then
we see Littlefinger who is probably
target for murder
in every single storyline that he's
involved in the other Lords of the Vale
probably want to get rid of him so she
would probably be happy to get rid of
him too Sansa probably wants to murder
him after what he did to her last season
and of course the dragons are probably
on to trying to eat everything that
passes within eyesight but just to loop
back around to the brand stuff you know
brand versus the night's king this
vision that he has where he turns around
and sees seven he's like oh [ __ ] it's
hard to tell where he is but he might be
looking at the weirwood just covered in
snow like this is what the world is
gonna look like during the long night
it's gonna be completely covered with
snow although technically it would
literally be night it would be dark all
the time so even though I would assume
that he's seeing into the past when he's
having this vision he might be seeing
into the future too or it could even be
the present really the pitches is that
it's gonna look a little bit like astral
projection so the show might play with
past present and future using that so
let me know in the comments what do you
most hype about from this trailer I
really just cannot wait to see what this
mast army of the night's king and the
White Walkers are going up against
because Dana Davis said that they
started to use so many special effects
that it's become cost prohibitive to
make the show which makes it sound like
there's like a ton more special effects
this season like you have drogon flying
over this giant crowd that's a big
special effect but all the White Walkers
stuff that's a lot of special effects
too so I think doing a lot more hardhome
type episode stuff is where a lot of
that extra cost came from but I guess
we'll find out also in really awesome
news new round of the giveaway starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I totally wasn't expecting this
new footage so what I'll probably do is
at least another bonus video on Sunday
before episode 1 airs but if there's
anything else that you guys want me to
cover this week just let me know in the
comments while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about the history of the Tower
of joy
you know what happened there the people
that were involved and you can click
here for the last big trailer video for
season six thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you